the question that we're just going to
begin with is you have some
distribution x some set of scores
temperatures
populations who knows they tell you what
the variance is
of that set of scores and then they say
okay if we
modified that distribution if we took
every single
x score that someone got and then if we
like
muck about with it if we do this
modification
then what effect would that have on the
variance can you tell me what the
variance of this distribution is
if you can tell me if i tell you what
the variance of this distribution is
okay are you going to give me an answer
max or are you suggesting a direction we
can go in
sorry say it again
okay so we're gonna definitely do some
substitution in a minute but what i
suggest is
actually let me ask this question first
hands up don't say it but hands up if
you're like
i'm pretty sure i know how to do this
question one two
yeah okay all right thank you hands down
okay
interesting so um i'm presuming that
means do you remember did you look at
your paper did you get this question
right
because we actually did i went back and
analyzed we did as a class not that
great on this question
do you remember getting it right you put
your hand up you're like okay it's fine
we need to remember for a second what is
what is
variance um all of the numbers that we
calculate for statistical analysis
generally they fit under two headings
they either cent measures of central
tendency
or measures of spread which one is
variance
it's a measure of spread like it's
literally in the name how much do things
vary okay do you remember how we
calculated does anyone remember what the
formula
is you want to start us off e to x
squared
ah okay so e to the did you say x
squared minus mu
so you're thinking of are you thinking
of sigma
sigma this guy here i know it vaguely
looks like an english e but it's
totally different so sigma so what does
this mean by the way before we go on
what does sigma tell us
we're adding up a bunch of things it's a
sum okay do you want to film me out yeah
square pretty close there is there is an
x and it is square but there's something
else
that happens okay so minus mu what is mu
again
this is the mean we also call it the
expected value depending on the context
we're in right
um what are we doing here what's going
on x is a score
and then minus mu why do i do this
i'm finding where does each score sit
in relation to the mean does that make
sense like are you far away from the
mean
are you close to the mean are you on the
mean right
um why do i square
i'm trying to get rid of negatives right
if i had a very and this is the exact
example i gave you last time
if i had a varied class a lot of people
above average and a lot of people below
average the same amount
if i just added all those differences if
i just added all of those
they might add up to zero even though
there's a very a varied
distribution right so i square in order
to get rid of that so you said when you
find
what we did with that specific score
so the z z-score is x minus
mu which is that over the standard
deviation do you remember that
okay so that's looking at each
particular one this is adding up a whole
bunch of them
now there's one piece missing i don't
just add up these i have to multiply by
sometimes anyone remember max
times expert value so i've got expected
value in here
mu it's the mean do you remember john
very good so this is the um probability
of each of those scores happening does
that make sense if i've got one event
and it's super likely to happen
then surely i should skew over towards
that guy rather than another one okay
which is low probability
okay so what i want us to do with this
is to actually just do a very simple
practical example and then for those of
you who asked me this question or those
of you who didn't put your hand up say i
know how to do this question
you tell me at what point it emerges
that you're like oh this question
i can now answer okay let me give you an
example and i'd love you to um draw this
with me we're going to do a probability
distribution and i'm going to give you a
very simple one okay
so draw up a little set of axes
and let's suppose we've got some some
game
uh like maybe darts or something or you
know when you're throwing balls at like
the
at a carnival and you're trying to get
it into a thing which gets you points
um in this game yeah something like that
um you either score 10 points or you
score
20 points okay so this is the game and
i'm interested in like what are the
chances that we will get one
or the other now we want to make sure
that all our probabilities add up to
one because that's the whole sequence so
let's just suppose and i'm just
manufacturing some simple
numbers to work with let's suppose
there's like a 40
chance a 40 chance that we score
a 10 and if the only other option is 20
then the complement of
40 would be 60 so i'll write that as 0.6
so somewhere around
i guess that's about halfway
0.6 so we would label
our axes accordingly i've got
probability on the vertical so
we normally write it in this sort of
unusual way where
x is the thing we're talking about and
little x is the actual scores
and then here are our scores okay now i
wonder if you can help me work out
what is the variance on this
distribution i mean we've literally got
our
definition here okay so can we do this
for this it's like a very small amount
of data okay
hmm so so the x's will be these scores
right so i will be doing some
substitution there but i immediately hit
a
road block as soon as i get past x
because um i need a mu
i need the mean and i don't know what
the mean is so i've got to work out mean
first right
yeah so it's going to be i've got to add
up the products
of the scores times their probability
score times probability so let's go
ahead and do that right
the expected value the mean in this
context will be
the sum of each score
multiplied by its probability is that
ring of l x
p of x is the way that we would write it
okay so we've got like a super simple
situation here we don't need to do any
complex calculations
the first score is 10 and its
probability is
0.4 there's the first one and then the
only other score is
20 and its probability is 0.6
okay cool uh 10 times 0.4 is 4
and then 4. and then 20 times 0.6
is i think that's 12 right
okay so i've got an expected value or a
mean
of 16. so far so good is that okay
now that i have mu i can use it when i'm
doing
my variance so my next line
will be starting to do this so variance
is going to equal okay so now i'm doing
this thing for each of the different
scores the first score is
10 i'm going to subtract mu which we
just calculated is
16 thank you very much i square that
because i
this this is a good example this is a
negative right that'll be negative so
i'll get that value in a second
and then what's the thing i multiply by
look again at the sigma notation p of x
which we said already from the first one
is 0.4 yeah
here doesn't say
their x equals e brackets
brackets x minus mu brackets squared
brackets
so that's another way of writing you can
see it's actually a whole different
like that starts talking about do you
remember we actually have different
formulas for calculating
variance two different ones and it
depends on which like what are you doing
with that like are you going to
integrate
next um or are you just evaluating the
numbers yes
can i yeah can i push on that e of x is
what it says oh you're talking about
expected value
which is e of x is x x that's this one
here
so do you do you remember we call it
mean but we also call it expected value
depending on what context we're in and
what we're going to do with that
later i thought that e was the second
one
are you talking about this this guy here
so
yeah so that just means add up a bunch
of things um sigma
s for sum just like the integral side is
just a minimum
that's right it's mu okay sorry where
were we are we okay is that okay does it
make sense now
can we keep going i'm not finished i've
only done one thing i've got to do the
other one right
what's the other one going to give me
plus
i've done one of the x minus mu squared
times p of x
20 minus 4. 20 minus 20 minus what
you think think it's mu again it's the
same it's the same mu
mu is always the same all the way
through i'm always comparing to the mean
so that'll be -16
then i square and then i multiply by
this probability which is 0.6
happy so far again yeah we've got
actually some reasonably simple numbers
here
this is 36 negative 6 all squared
multiplied by that then you've got this
that's
4 squared which is 16.
okay uh you're probably going to get to
a number that's what's this this is like
what's that fourteen point four is it
fourteen point four
four five four point eight okay can
someone tell you what it's equal to the
whole thing
the whole thing no yeah just you might
as well simplify them
someone got it say again 24
on the diet thumbs up okay fantastic